Kaleigh is with us in miami hi Kaley how
are you I'm great
thanks so much for taking my call sure
what's up so my husband and I have been
following the baby steps for quite some
time and we have note that except for
our home we were pretty close it's not
to having a fully funded emergency fund
and we are going through fertility
treatments now and we've been through
one round and it pretty much depleted us
not fully pretty much and so we've
started to build that again but we're
faced with having to go through that
again
and so my question for you is should we
fund this round with what we have in our
current emergency fund tour I have a
mutual fund that was given to me by a
great uncle when I was younger and that
was purposed for my wedding when I
became of age and when we got married we
didn't use everything in that mutual
fund so how much is in there only about
thirty one thousand and how much are
they are you paying for your treatments
right now we're looking at about four
grand for our treatment but that will
actually in full for the full treatment
right what we have upcoming will be
probably about ten grand I would cash in
your mutual fund and I would fund your
emergency fund fully because it's not
fully funded and I would use the excess
money above that to do the infertility
treatment okay but as important as these
treatments are because I don't think
there's anything much more fun than
having kids so I'm with you I'm with you
on having this on your journey and
how important it is to you I'm sure as
important as it is it's not an emergency
okay and we use the emergency fund for
emergencies and so even if that mutual
fund was part of our retirement that
we've been saving in a retirement
account though
no no just a mutual fund so you wouldn't
have a mutual fund if you don't have
them an emergency fund funded and I
would use investments like that excess
money above a mutual fund to pay for
infertility treatments which is what
you're doing okay last piece of advice
can you imagine that I've answered
questions about this subject many times
over the last 30 years the answer is yes
I have okay I don't know anything about
it other than I have answered a bunch of
questions and I've asked each time what
you're paying and how you're paying and
I hear in those answers a vast array of
different programs different ways to go
about this in terms of you know you pay
a larger amount and you get a very large
guaranteed number of tries versus one
offs that can add up quickly with some
different programs out there so if you
haven't you may have but if I were in
your shoes I would spend a lot of time
researching the business model of these
people and understand real clearly what
my best options are to accomplish this
goal because it's so emotional sometimes
people don't look at it and they overpay
for the processes that they're using
matter of fact I'll just say oftentimes
they do